[Music]
i do have to tell you about sex and city
yeah no hit it rich white women
going to the middle east
to solve feminism in the middle east
carrie bradshaw who writes a sex column
in new york city goes to the middle east
and brings feminism with her she's gonna
undo
hundreds of years of like thousands of
years of you know culture and everything
just because they're like you know what
you should flaunt what you got and
you're like is that like does is this
the people we want to be the voice of
this you know problem or whatever what
do you think
it got on rotten tomatoes not that
ratings matter but i would say less than
a uh i mean i would say maybe a 20
15. some movie came out as a superhero
movie and the rating was really high and
i said offhand like this might have been
in high school i said it's a group of
people i'm like man you know the studio
just like got some people like pump that
[ __ ] up and this kid goes are you
implying that a studio would fake
reviews are you saying like rotten
tomatoes would corroborate that he's
like that would literally ruin the
integrity of the site like jeremiah i
know but the world is a lot different
than you think he like was [ __ ] so
offended that i could even put that
forward yeah yeah i was like yeah like i
just [ __ ]
that was a primal moment for me like he
said all that i was like yes he's like
okay yeah he just shook his head was
like
whatever man like just so [ __ ] upset
honestly dude i think you got a problem
yeah
no you got to watch yourself actually
but the uh just to do a quick summary uh
carrie bradshaw which is uh sarah
jessica parker in such a city is the
protagonist of sex and city she's the
main character and she is probably the
most evil person that has ever been
portrayed
as a protagonist ever
i have seen all of sopranos i've seen
breaking bad gary bradshaw is just
the worst person out of both both of
those people have killed people yeah
carrie's never killed somebody but she's
still a worse human being sarah jessica
parker is married to uh ferris bueller
who killed somebody yeah yeah i know
about that yeah yeah or matthew
broderick we'll just call him ferris be
like yeah yeah yeah yeah but the uh
so she's married to him and if you've
also did
sarah jessica parker's instagram is
[ __ ] weird i've been watching this
new show and her profile picture is a
compressed photo of her eye so she she
grabbed her iphone and like just took a
picture of her eye like that what a
creepy ass
yeah it's weird but she's so it's so
this is you know it's all about the
whole show the the first
series sexist city i legitimately love
like it's a very fun watcher even though
carrie is the worst person ever she gets
everything she wants learns nothing
along the way yeah she just ruins
people's lives she's just kind of a
horrible person yeah and she has like
this group of friends who are way more
interesting as characters but blindly
support all of the horrible things she
does that's like the original series the
movies come out it's just like basically
extended episodes with like trying to
shove these four women into social
situations they should not be in this
new show and just like that it's it's so
bad
but it's just something where it's like
could it get worse can it keep getting
worse and it does and it's very good
so it's just every kind of new
like you know political
uh social like anything that is being
brought up now that's like of concern
they're like we're going to have the
wealthiest people
60 year old white women in new york
be
exactly be the voice and be the uh the
the defense to what's happening
and it's been just absolutely
mind-boggling well i just have to quote
this review for sex and sleep too how
did they get this so wrong this movie
truly amazed me every single time i
thought it couldn't be any worse or more
stupid it somehow does itself in every
scene it's a unique specimen in how to
make a terrible movie i want to watch it
now when i tell people i'm like you
should watch sex and city you know they
always think of carrie and the whole
like thing that she used to do in the
first series where she would be like a
dialogue of her talking to herself when
she was writing in her journal yeah was
the miranda right was me
cheating on my boyfriend for the fifth
time affecting my relationship with dogs
and you're like
huh it's usually that kind of thing well
i love this
you know naturally people are upset
about the like presentation of women and
like the emirates
then someone's like it wasn't even
filmed in abu dhabi and i'm laughing at
these hollywood people being like yeah
we should make a [ __ ] movie where you
guys go to like the middle east and like
you saw feminism the mom makes it yeah
that's what it sounds like
yeah basically
and then they're like okay well uh
[ __ ] how are we gonna shoot this in
the middle east arizona yeah we just do
it in new mexico it's basically the same
thing
there's not a lot of uh trees uh sarah
can you uh shoot for like six days yeah
we'll get you in and out of there you're
just gonna [ __ ] you know hit a few
lines it'll be
by the
baby and then when we put it
international oh my god oh my god that's
where we're gonna see the real money
it's gonna be like how michael bay gets
his profits
you